the Iowa caucuses typically force
candidates to lay out their farm program
platforms both president Trump and his
Democratic challenges are promising to
continue or expand programs that provide
large subsidies to farmers the one clear
difference between the president and
most of his challenges is that many
Democrats would direct more subsidies to
smaller farms the president also gave
farmers twenty five billion dollars in
ad-hoc market facilitation payments to
compensate them for the damages trade
policies have done to their revenues not
that there's much difference between mr.
Trump and most of the challenges on
trade like the president they seem to
believe that US exports are good the US
imports are bad so trade deals that
lower tariffs are bad only Michael
Bloomberg supports free trade finally
most candidates are paying little
attention to public funding for
agricultural research one program that
benefits farmers and consumers and keeps
us agriculture globally competitive
instead they prefer to spend taxpayer
dollars on direct deposit subsidies to
farmers to win their rural votes what do
you think about the presidential
candidates farm programs let us know in
our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI